c'est même par exemple le pc que tu en
fis le pays et ça ça rien glissé retour
parce qu'ils ont plus rien là bas donc
tu te dis qu'est ce qu'il en reste
en fait
[Musique]
salut à tous et cirrus north je suis
actuellement au liban plus précisément à
l'est à la frontière avec la syrie se
trouve derrière ces montagnes je venais
avec le média brut pour vous parler des
conditions de vie des réfugiés syriens
dans le pays et pour vous partager leurs
témoignages
[Musique]
le liban est un pays du proche orient
qui compte approximativement 4,5
millions d'habitants
à cela il faut ajouter environ 1,5
million de réfugiés syriens qui depuis
2011 fut la guerre dans leur pays au
liban c'est donc une personne sur quatre
qui est réfugié
[Musique]
donc là on est dans une tente assez
classique des camps de réfugiés syriens
au liban c'est yasmine qui nous a
gentiment invité chez elle
chocques l'âme donc c'est une tante qui
est assez spacieuse par rapport aux
autres tentes ya une famille nombreuse
qui vit ici
donc ça reste très rudimentaire il ya
que deux pièces donc celle là dans
lequel toute la vie qui se fait et il ya
une chambre il n'y a pas de cuisine
comme vous pouvez le constatez donc la
cuisine et à l'extérieur on est sur des
matériaux qui sont très rudimentaires
aussi donc on a quelques planches de
bois et sinon on a juste de la toile en
fait une toile de l'onu contre des vrais
intempéries il n'y a pas grand-chose qui
résistent ici l'hiver c'est à dire qu'il
fait froid aussi parce que ça m'a isolé
demain si il y à des pluies
torrentielles qui viennent voilà on est
à même le sol
forcément ça va être inondé et à
beaucoup de familles syriennes au liban
qui vivent dans ce type de logement
c'est des conditions de vie extrêmement
difficile notamment pour des enfants
quoi
[Musique]
pour bien comprendre l'exode des syriens
au liban il faut remonter jusqu'en 2011
ça fait leur disant que bachar al assad
est au pouvoir la situation dans le pays
notamment d'un point de vue économique
et en matière de libertés publiques ne
s'est pas améliorée à ce moment là plus
la moitié de la population c est la
moins de 25 ans et un tiers des jeunes
sont au chômage
mal quel niveau d'éducation à s'élever
dans le pays en écho au printemps arabe
la population manifeste alors pour
demander plus de démocratie et plus de
droits
mais la répression du régime est
extrêmement violente arrestations
emprisonnements tortures tirs à balles
réelles sur les manifestants
le pays sombre peu à peu dans le chaos
et la guerre civile
depuis le début de la guerre il y aurait
eu plus de cinq cent dix mille morts en
syrie
et selon le haut commissariat des
nations unies pour les réfugiés les
combats incessants ont fait 6 6 millions
de déplacés dans le pays et 5,6 millions
dans le monde
[Musique]
apparemment il ya des les enfants qui
ont préparé des petits jouets à nous
montrer on va voir ça tout de suite
c'est vraiment le coup alors dites moi
vous faites quoi ici exactement qu'est
ce que vous fabriquez
tel est le lot 1 à bordeaux
vous mettez de la charte en boîte de
comment tu soude les deux là le
plastique ne pas partager avec les
rennes du coach il est vrai
est ce que tu peux nous parler de la vie
d'une adolescente dans un camp de
réfugiés syriens comme celui de cette
manière là et tu fais quoi plus tard
notre lablad voilà où mène le travail en
aval et au monde j'espère que tes rêves
vont se réaliser
sortir du camp et se trouver un job dans
le make-up maquillage coiffure
comme tout ce que je te souhaite
[Musique]
la source l'ensemble des problèmes des
réfugiés syriens au liban
c'est sans doute l'absence de
de papiers légaux on considère par
exemple qu'il ya 75 % des refuges faire
des syriens qui sont présents liban qui
ne disposent pas de permis de résidence
légale ça veut dire que ce sont des
personnes des familles des parents des
enfants qui ne vont pas vouloir se
déplacer par craint de se faire
contrôler par crainte de se faire
ensuite arrêté parce qu'ils n'ont pas
c'est cette documentation légale
parle avec eux depuis hier aujourd'hui
et raconte genre lors elles coupent
leurs aspirations et c'est bien que
voulait devenir pilote et le 9 février
dans le make up
il y en a qui font des dossiers pour
partir au canada en italie
les pays européens et je comprends cette
envie de lui de partir d'ici
comme vous avez pu le voir les réfugiés
syriens vivent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles
ils ont parfois vécu de vrai traumatisme
là on à beyrouth la capitale du liban
on va dans l'hôpital public le plus
grand du pays pour rencontrer d'autres
réfugiés syriens qui bénéficient d'une
aide en santé mentale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous me racontez votre
histoire est ce qui fait que vous êtes
ici aujourd'hui c'est la rolls
feuilletage calendar man ou quelques
émules bethmale bande de gaza neuf à la
malbaie
enfin al aloul est l'argent m'a donné
jean aulagnier nous balade nani owen
notera surtout la météo afin de prier
culbute
mais pour travailler mais shipton jours
d'activisme la loi dadvsi la mafia même
temps il ya des renards date à bercy
tablé cette année la balade
la maquette mais ça y est
ayem boussole
maintenant 8 ans raison perdu perdu leur
maison en fait c'est même pas ils ont
fui le pays et c'est que ils ont fuit le
pays
et ça ça rien qui certes ont parce
qu'ils ont plus rien là bas et donc tu
te dis qu'est ce qui leur reste
en fait et ça pourrait être le raconte
avec ses enfants à côté qui joue rue
tous qui se marrent et entre deux un
truc de larmes d'un sourire pour ses
enfants
c'est hyper c'est hyper fort tueur c'est
hyper triste fait de mettre des visages
dessus d'avoir quelqu'un en face à toi
qui traquent tout ça et qu'ils savent il
a vécu des choses extrêmement difficile
il ya une dimension empathique il ya
aussi une autre dimension qui est que le
déni n'est plus possible
cinq ans mais personne n'aura comme ce
soir bon bah c'est pas c'est pas au jt
de france 2 entre entre nous deux je
sais pas quoi enfin tu vois c'est juste
avant un match de foot quoi non c c'est
l'histoire d'un semblable
[Musique]
ici on est dans un centre de santé
mentale comment vous ai dit si
concrètement dans machete kills se payer
ou non signé qui se sont relayés à
mumbai en inde au marché qu'il est
[Musique]
fait de me raconter tout ça c'est hyper
courageuse et perfore donc à ça qui me
passionne ce qui nous passionne aussi
c'est cette force où elle est capable de
m'expliquer comment elle a perdu sa mère
comment elle a fui son son chez soi pour
sauver ses enfants et tous et en même
temps voilà il ya ces quatre gamins un
côté il ya sa petite fille de 11 mois
qui comparent tous les bas à la chapelle
est calme wahou
quelle maîtrise quelle force quelle
c'est admirable on se rend compte que
voilà les problèmes psychologiques sont
extrêmement graves on en parle très peu
alors potentiellement ça concerne des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés qui ont
vécu
des traumatismes considère que ça risque
d'être un problème explosifs dans les
années voire dans les générations à
venir car ce sont d une génération
entière d'enfants de jeunes adultes est
évidemment d'adultes aussi qui sont
marqués par non seulement par les
traumatismes liés à la guerre qu'ils ont
pu vivre un enfant qui même s'il est
aujourd'hui au liban depuis je ne sais
pas depuis cinq six ans s'il a quitté la
syrie à l'âge de 3-4 ans ça veut dire
qu'il a forcément entendu des choses
qu'il a forcément vu des choses et qu'il
a vécue intégré dit gérer des situations
de stress qui ont été vécues par ses
parents par par son entourage par sa
communauté
les séquelles moreau psychologiques sont
sont extrêmement violent et même ça
continue serre que là ils sont sortis de
civet elle racontait que embrouillé avec
discrimination et que ses enfants
subissent la discrimination dans le
quartier à l'école etc
c'est hyper important que ces enfants là
soit suis fait que ce soit pas elle le
disait elle-même soit pas un tabou ils
souhaitent par un problème de venir
discuté de ça avec des spécialistes et
un jour justement si la syrie arrive à
se reconstruire
il est important qu effectivement les
générations de syriens qui vont revenir
qui vont naître soit protégé dans ces
problématiques de santé mentale quand
elles existent elles sont prêtes à se
déclarer
[Musique]
et